hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on apex like it's again
and as you could see season 2 has just
started my download is still going I'm
at like 30% done but I had the ready to
start going so I can show off the battle
pass and we got a lot of things involved
in here we got new skins we got music
distant ship we got backgrounds and
stuff we're gonna be going through all
that stuff whether it be free or premium
as well as the level 100 skin and
possibly a level 110 I have not looked
at this so this is going to be a perfect
raw reaction to all of it so let's get
started with it
so first up at level 1 as soon as you
buy it you're going to be getting the
m600 Spitfire skin called the
Intimidator look spiffy as hell we're
gonna be getting a gibraltar skin a
bangalore skin and a pathfinder skin as
well always nice to see what some battle
pass XP you're gonna be getting 10%
bonus the top 5 and win XP and this can
stack to everyone in the party and
according to this if you get every
single one in the battle path it will be
about 300 percent which is pretty
[ __ ] wild we also have a music disc
according to my audio track it that
sounded a bit quiet I will try to
hopefully increase the audio but
hopefully it isn't too bad and it just
doesn't look like I'm being very silent
but yes we do have a music pack and that
is going to be a thing when you're now
skydiving as that character so Watson
will get a say music pack I believe when
it I believe it is just her so when you
are playing as Watson you'll beginning
that music pack went skydiving we're
also gonna be getting some free stuff
which is some stat tracks which you
don't really give a [ __ ] about prowler
skin is and it's alright we got a jobber
altar background which looks really
insane the tip of the spear I'm [ __ ]
with this a lot there's some detailed
art that's gonna be in your loading
screaming of you load up the game as
well as more stat tracks a purple apex
which will give you a 7 percent chance
of legendary but guaranteed epic which
is always nice to see more stat tracks a
very P 2020 pretty average skin more
stat tracks more stat tracks and apex
coins a hell of a lot of stacked tracks
actually how far does this go we're also
gonna be getting a hundred and twenty
crafting materials at level 9 a bangle
or skydive emote which is called salute
that looks pretty nice does a little
backflip does a upside-down salute
that's pretty dope one once unlocked
this skydive emote will automatically be
equipped to the character and can be
used during the skydive that's really
sick I'm really glad they started adding
that stuff it's very unique to the game
we're also gonna be getting more stat
tracks you can already see it on screen
I need to keep saying that we're also
going to get more battle up past XP
later in the early levels a regular apex
pack on top of a ain't free apex back so
that's two in a row that's pretty dope a
longbow skin called Riptide pretty
average because it is a rare skin the
ravenous skin or the ravenous loading
screen for bloodhound if that looks
super detailed I'm [ __ ] with that a
lot another apex pack
another music pack as well looks really
just from the sound of it I can already
tell it's gonna be sick it's more than
that techno bass that octane is really
into another Mozambique skin some apex
packs as well apex coins a I think yeah
that's a frame for a lifeline pretty
nice as well apex pack crafting
materials a bloodhound skydive emote
called the stoic stance does another
little backflip and just kind of sits
there all chill very professional like
he always is
apex packs a lot of there's a lot of
Apex facts I'm realizing from this the
loading screen that's been a super big
thing for Mirage than me myself and I we
saw that in the one of the early
trailers of the game so if your Mirage
guy definitely be copping that super
dope 25 we get our first legendary skin
which is the Prince of Darkness a more
kind of nightly kind of darker night
version of the caustic skin it very good
personally I'm not a big caustic guy but
if you are caustic man I highly
recommend grabbing this and if you get
the battle past bundle which is the one
that shoots you all the way up to level
25 you will get this unlocked
immediately on purchase we get a havoc
skin not too bad Apex coins at level 50
some wraith frame that's cool some more
crafting materials on there Scott IV mo
for caustic feel the power
nice I'm noticing that these guys do a
lot of backflips I'm not entirely sure
if that's the point and all of this but
it's doing school nonetheless he's very
he's really showing off his psychotic
side we gonna free Watson's skin if you
get to level 30 that's gonna be the hot
rod skin not too bad I mean it's always
gonna be it's a free walk Watson's skin
is seeing as she doesn't really have
much to seeing as she's a new character
very exciting to see that we got another
XP boost some more apex packs some
general skins a loading script for
caustic all black arts or avenged
personally my favorite skin until that
at this battle pass so if I was a
caustic man I would grab this instantly
he's such a good character in terms of
gameplay maybe not so much but the still
the backstory and just how he looks
super good with him
that's gonna be a Bangalore Music pack
sounds really nice got that army feel to
it Craver skin not too bad
it's once again it is a rare so it's not
too crazy more Apex coins a lot of
crafting materials new skydiving mode
for Gibraltar the front-row seat he and
that little crisscross applesauce and
we're going back to kindergarten
whatever you guys want to call it some
people call it Indian stance but I'm
more of the crisscross applesauce type
of guy we got the XP boost some more
apex coins a new L star the new weapon L
star that's going to be getting a skin a
loading screen called liberation I used
this in one of my thumbnails too
interesting that was one of the concept
arts for Wraith when she was held in the
mental facility by the IMC I did a
little lore video on her so you can
always check that out
skydive email for lifeline a little
backflip with the peace out symbol
always about that peace in positivity I
respect that alternator skin called
battle class but not too bad hundred
apex coins bloodhound frame crafting
materials and then at level 50 we get a
guaranteed apex pack that's sick moving
on we got some generic stuff the loading
screen that is the one I also used in a
thumbnail for Watson pretty dope banner
frame a lot of Apex coins skydive emote
called the curtain call you know a
little kiss to the crowd their Mirage I
like that just some generic skins I
won't be showing all of these because
like most of this stuff is really basic
I didn't even notice that mirages got a
little music back there that's really
cool
another loading screen we got Pathfinder
called seeking the Creator that's a
really nice looking skin I'm pretty sure
that's his one of his like brown skins
that he has I forgot what that's called
but I don't remember seeing all this
blue technical stuff so that could be a
little hint to a possibly new legendary
variation of that skin which I'm always
down for that was a really nice
bloodhound type music Pacquiao bought
the hunt and all that stuff I got a
Bangalore frame always about shooting
the targets on sight we got a full
circle which is him going in a circle
while running I remember seeing this at
a trailer really hyped for that octane
skydive emo I cannot wait to grab that
at 70 XP boost alternator skin really
nice it actually I believe it moves
that's really cool
standard skin loading screen for
Bangalore that's called the heroes fall
that was also in some of her concept art
these loading screens seem to be the
concept art which I'm obviously
completely down for and then we had 75
we have the legendary octane skin called
the Jade tiger super cool looking skin
definitely to be grabbing that let me
know if you guys are big octane fans
more apex coins a new Watson frame like
the way pretty nice we have a Pathfinder
called high friends where he looks back
at everybody does a little wave that's
for the cheeky loading screen for
lifeline saving the guy once again
another concept art piece
we have another music pack for costaq
pretty dope I like that menacing type of
beat - the bet and the background sword
in the stone for Pathfinder shout out
King Arthur
we got another we got a Watson skydive
emote a little graceful fall kind of
like a nice really clean backflip I like
that nothing too crazy but just looks
really elegant and then we move on to 94
we got the record breaker which is the
octane loading screw in octane loading
screen another concept art of him
running the gauntlet super dope a
wraiths skydive emo for flipped the rift
that was a lot of backflips I think that
was like what three okay I counted three
or four on that and that was really nice
ending it with a Gibraltar frame that's
gonna be the last purple we beat we're
gonna be getting that looks really cool
any Gibraltar players would love that
120 crafting materials the are 301 iron
rampage that gun looks [ __ ] insane
and spiffy I like that and then the 110
variation is the gold rampage so this is
gonna be the gold one compared to the
other one that's pretty that's more
purple and then we also get the season
two battle charge level for hitting 110
super excited on that one so yeah guys
that was gonna be the battle pass I just
did a little bit of quick looking at
some of the stuff that we're gonna be
getting so as I as I noticed you will
get enough crafting materials to get a
legendary saying as you go from level 1
to 100 and you complete the entire
battle pass you will have enough
crafting materials to get yourself one
legendary and there's actually enough
apex coins to get you the 10 pack for
the 10 apex pack so I believe it's
actually exactly a thousand so if you
have some leftover it's just more but if
you have 0 like I do you'll be getting
exactly 10 apex packs on top of the
billions of apex packs we're getting
just in this past so I'm super excited
and as for the answer really if you
should buy this battle pass personally I
would totally recommend it I think this
is going to be a super good battle pass
super good season we got a lot of actual
content that we enjoy and not really
being taken up like the stat tracks and
the voice lines and stuff the loading
screens are nice the music stuff is
gonna be a little bit subjective because
that's only in certain parts when you're
skydiving but it's really nice to hear
that but the legendary skins really do
make up for it but yeah let me know what
you guys think about this stuff in the
comments below I'm super excited to hop
into apex once this is done downloading
I think I'm
like 50% 45% got a while to go before I
can play some games but yeah on top of
that we also have the daily challenges I
think I believe I stated that in the
beginning maybe not but we do have
battle past challenges daily and weekly
challenges that will be giving you
battle pass XP just to make your life a
hell of a lot easier we have very simple
ones that are gonna be for the daily
which is you know get 5 head shots but
the weekly ones are getting five
challenges 10 challenges and then
there's going to be one week of 7 it
looks like or it says o of 7 for the
first week so this is all this stuff and
if you happen to get all seven you will
be getting an extra battle pass level
for that one so lots of ways to be
ranking up it should not be that hard to
get a level 100 I'll be I liked envy if
you do enjoy guys I cover Apex legends
on the channel as you guys can tell I'm
mainly known for the lore of the apex
legends characters I covered Watson in a
past video as I stayed in multiple times
throughout the covered Wraith I covered
octane as well so yeah if you guys want
to check those out those will be in a
playlist as somewhere on my channel but
definite go to grab those and watch
those videos let me know your thoughts
they also in the comments let me know if
you guys think the battle paths will be
worth it I think that the battle pass is
gonna be very word that for season 2 I
wasn't I would definitely say no to
season 1 but for season 2 I definitely
think so especially because you can
obviously get the $10 one use the daily
challenges and you will still be able to
get really far in the battle path
because of these challenges and you
don't have to just grind yeah I'd like
to be if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new like I've said multiple times
and peace out guys enjoy the rest of
your day and enjoy season 2 as well let
me know your thoughts on that
[Music]